[تصفيق]
انا نعلم كم هو عدد هؤلاء المجرمين
وولاياتنا سوف تكون اكثر امانا وفي
الولايات المتحده سوف نوقف انتشار
المخدرات والحجره غير الشرعيه
وهذا يعني ان يكون لدينا حدودا حقيقيه كما
فعلنا في جنوب كارولاينا
لابد لشركات ان تقوم بتوظيف الامريكيين
وليس المخالفين
في امريكا التي اتوق اليها للجميع ان يضع
ثقته في الانتخابات
وسوف يتم العمل على بناء كافه الاراضي كما
فعلنا في جنوب كارولاينا
ان امريكا التي نطوق اليها سوف تكون افضل
للجميع لان واشنطن سوف تعمل على خدمه
الشعب
وسوف نقوم بانهاء ووضع حد
لاثراء الشركات الكبرى والعمل على تعزيز
المؤسسات الحكوميه ووظائفها وعندما يتعلق
الامر بالسياسيين
فسوف نقوم باشعال النيران من حولهم
فان عملهم هو ليس ان يروا الاشياء على
محطات الشاشه والتلفزه بل ان يقفوا على
المشاكل بصوره حقيقيه تلك المشاكل التي
تكون من صنيعتهم
وفي امريكا التي اطوق اليها فان سياسيين
الدائمين لابد لهم ان يتقاعدوا
سوف يكون هناك اجل زمني محدد
لمن هم في الكونغرس
سوف يكون هناك
فتره زمنيه محدده لخدمه الاعضاء في
الكونجرس في عند سن
ال 75 والاهم من ذلك فانني ارى امريكا سوف
تكون قويه بفضل حاله الفخر والكرامه وليس
بسبب وضع الضعف والهشاشه التي نعيشها
يا ميسي امريكا التي اطوق اليها سوف تفوز
في القرن الحادي والعشرين بفضل الشجاعه
والقوه التي نمتلكها للدفاع عن قيمنا ودحر
اعدائنا
[تصفيق]
القوات العسكريه لا تقوم بقرع طبول الحروب
بل تقوم بوقف دابر الحروب
وفي امريكا سوف نبدا بالعمل على التنقيب
عن المزيد من النفط والغاز والتوقف عن
جلبها من فنزويلا
وسوف نقف مع حلفائنا بدءا من اسرائيل الى
اوكرانيا وسوف نواجه اعدائنا في روسيا
وايران
وفي امريكا التي اطوق اليها فان الصين
الشيوعيه لن تجرؤ على فعل ما فعلته كما
كان الحال بالنسبه للحزب
السوفيتي السابق فسوف تنتهي مع صفحات
التاريخ
ان ادراك هذه الرؤيه لن يكون امرا سهلا بل
سوف يحتاج الى مستوى غير مسبوق من
الالتزام من قبلنا جميعا يتطلب الامر
الايمان والرغبه في المضيء بعيدا عن الحل
القائم والقيام باشياء لم نفعلها في
السابق
[تصفيق]
مثل
ارسالي اقوى سيده الى البيت الابيض
[تصفيق]
وسوف اكون دائما ممتنه للشعب في
الذين امنوا
عندما قمت
بمقارعه المشرعين في الولايات المتحده لم
اكن لاحقق الفوز انذاك لكننا اليوم فسوف
اعمل على ذلك عندما ترشحت لاكون حاكمه كان
الجميع يتعجب ومع ذلك استطعت كسب تلك
الجوله
وقد تم تعيين وتكليفك وسفيره للامم
المتحده وبعضهم قال بانني افتقر الى
الخبره ولن افلح في هذا المنظر